I want to just focus a little bit more
on entrepreneurship I want to understand
why or if you do think entrepreneurship
is so important and also the world has
changed a lot in the last 20 years so
would you say that being an entrepreneur
now is far more important than it was 20
30 years ago a year uh do I think it's
more important now than 20 30 years ago
I don't know if I could say more
important or less important I think it
was definitely more important 200 years
ago 100 years ago because they needed to
really set the tone and get it going uh
what I do think is happening today as
well as intrapreneurs are becoming just
as valuable as entrepreneurs the only
difference between an entrepreneur and
an entrepreneur is the one guy put up
the money and risked it and the other
guy didn't aside from that the
entrepreneur still works as hard still
as obsessed about the company 24 7 and
still wanting to grow the company owns a
piece of the company a Steve Ballmer
who's a 100 billion dollar guy he's an
entrepreneur a Tim Cook is an
entrepreneur Steve Jobs on the second
time around when he came back he was an
entrepreneur so I think the pressures of
having to like I I would love to see
Twitter profiles and Instagram profiles
changing to saying entrepreneur just as
much as we see entrepreneur because
companies that are creating an
environment of Entrepreneurship are able
to stay Innovative and trendy where
companies that are just here's how we do
it you better do this they're not going
to produce entrepreneurs but going back
to answer your question for you on the
entrepreneur side I think
markets need entrepreneurs I think a
Detroit today needs to figure out a way
to get rid of all the politicians and
bring the entrepreneurs in I think a New
York needs to eliminate as much politics
that they have and remember this city
became the financial capital of the
world because of entrepreneurs let's get
back to that if I was a governor of a
country of a state or if I was a
president of a country I would I would
make a very big investment and focus and
emphasis on recognizing the
entrepreneurs the job creators and then
seeing what area doesn't have enough of
them and giving incentives to go into
those communities like we're in Fort
Lauderdale right do you think there's
more entrepreneurs in Fort Lauderdale or
Miami right now I'm going to guess Miami
you're right it is Miami and look what's
happening to Miami right so yeah if I'm
running Fort Lauderdale I'm finding out
a creative way to bring people here you
know if I'm more on the inside I'm going
to try to bring people in from Orlando
but some markets needed more than others
and some countries needed more than
others but I think you need both
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurs today
do you think people are walking
quoting yourself entrepreneurs when
they're entrepreneurs or Freelancers
these days do you think that the term
entrepreneurs sort of lost its true
meaning but you know here's here's how
it also looks okay you ever met people
that think they're very good looking but
they're not yes okay you ever met a girl
that thinks she's so super attractive
but she's not probably okay Annie you
ever met a girl who is super attractive
but she doesn't know she's attractive of
course and have you ever met a guy
that's extremely handsome but he's like
not confident about himself right so how
do you tell them apart right the way you
tell it apart is by what the market
calls you you can go to a local business
Place get a DBA and create a business
card call yourself CEO but if you're the
only person that calls you a CEO you're
not a CEO right yeah if hundreds of
other people call you their CEO you're a
true CEO you can call yourself an
entrepreneur but if nobody in the
marketplace sees you as an entrepreneur
you're a delusional man it's okay A lot
of people are you know a lot of people
think they're sexy but they're not and
that's okay if you think you're sexy
more power to you some people think they
have to take care of their health some
people think they have to exercise
there's certain people that think no I'm
300 pounds and I'm sexy I don't think
I'm sexy when I'm 300 pounds I remember
when I hit 257 pounds and I look at my
wife I said babe what is up with that
belly of mine I'm looking at the mirror
I said that's nasty oh my God what the
hell happened I'm always 240. I got 17
pounds I got to figure something out so
then you lose the weight because to me
257 doesn't look right so typically the
guys that are true entrepreneurs or
doers or entrepreneurs their level of
expectation of themselves is so much
higher than those that they're not did
you see the recent movie by Elvis pres
the Elvis movie I actually didn't watch
it but I heard it was amazing oh my God
so the guy's name is Austin Butler
Austin's Austin Butler right if you've
not seen the movie do yourself a favor
go first watch his interview with Jesus
I watched the interview my brother told
me to watch it together you watched a
guy and he says uh you know I mean you
know I'm more like the guy that just you
know I struggle with not being good
enough and you know I feel like I'm not
there yet and you know I got work to do
and I'm here in Elvis's house and that's
what I'm dealing with and you're like I
believe him I don't think he's being
fake like he's being authentic I watched
a movie twice in the first week because
I just believed this guy right and my
kids watched it we watch we watched the
interview together there's there's a
certain weird insecurity in the people
that constantly get better and improve
they don't think they're there yet or
good enough yet so if you automatically
want to call yourself an entrepreneur or
whatever
and you haven't really ran a business
maybe it makes you feel better totally
fine I understand the whole concept what
is the concept from uh that one movie uh
JT Marlin what is that movie with the
stock Brokers the fake stock Brokers
yeah but what's the movie's name a
boiler room right the fake it till you
make it right I understand there's a
place for fake it till you make it but
you better make it you know what I'm
saying if you're gonna fake it till you
never make it it's like people are
burned out of you talking about you're
going to be there one day but you can
fake it for a minute but you better
eventually make it I've heard that
before and I think it's fascinating the
idea that entrepreneurs are people who
have such high expectations for
themselves and nothing is good enough
and that's what keeps them going is that
what keeps you going
yeah for me it's a vision so it's a few
different things one I have a site like
right now where I'm eating at my at the
lunch restaurant I go to and the guy
next to me says hey Pat can we do
something to come he's a guy that
follows the content I said she wants to
do book signing so he starts saying do
you not have collected baseball cards I
have every baseball player's autographed
since 1946. I said what he says every
player that's ever placed in played in
baseball Major Leagues I have their
autograph I said since 1940s he says how
many players are there thirteen thousand
wow and then he says I heard you're also
into cars I said you know what's so
crazy I thought I was into cars I don't
like cars I have a truck parked outside
every day I drive a truck okay F-150
it's a Shelby it's nice but that's what
I do last three years that's all I drive
the other night we're going to uh Mario
just recently got engaged and we're
going to Casa D'Angelo for dinner I tell
Jen Jen let's take the Ferrari out no
babe my skirt and I would much I'm like
ah let's just take the we took one of
the SUVs or whatever we went there but I
tell you if I look at baseball card I'm
12 years old if I hold one of the cards
you're going to be like this guy's not
44. he's childlike
business to me I feel that way when I'm
playing business I feel like I'm 12
years old I feel like we're playing a
game and it's a freaking blast I'm only
playing this game right the other part
of it is vision and the other part of it
is my uh one of our relatives insulted
my dad when I was 25 years old at a
Christmas party and he did it right in
front of me and I made a promise to my
dad that I'm going to keep till the day
I die I say the world is going to know
your last name and I was a nobody at
that time I'm a regular 25 year old I'm
making maybe six figures no one knows
who I am I've never produced the content
ever produced the video I've never done
nothing like that but I said the World's
Gonna know your last name and you're
going to be very proud that you
sacrifice everything to bring us to U.S
you're going to see what I'm gonna do
I'm hopefully you're going to be alive
to see all this stuff and obviously he's
getting a glimpse of it right now so
game long-term vision and Pops is the
reason why I love this game that's
beautiful I like that a lot
foreign
[Music]